[Music]
I wanted to do a costume for convention
I wanted it to be amazing and I wanted
to spend almost no money doing it
[Music]
in computer animation your job usually
is to make something that's digital look
as real as possible so I kind of did the
inverse of that by making a practical
effect look digital
[Music]
[Music]
bringing these things out of your past
into you know whatever scenario I
brought the costume in fear as I
mentioned you know I think that brings a
lot of joy because people don't expect
the scene this here is really love
making people happy
performing spun creating art is fun and
when I get to combine those two things
it's the best feeling the biggest
challenge in doing this is doing a good
service to the character representing
them properly when I put it on I'm
puppeteering the character more than
just wearing it so doing anatomy studies
is really important to these head-to-toe
[Music]
I grew up with an interest in science so
I loved zoology and biology and the
mechanics of how animals and bodies work
but when I went to college I decided to
take art and said that people a passion
about art and sharing experiences with
other people so I like to blend my
interests together when I create my
artwork
[Music]